forma de las pensiones es una de las
medidas de este segundo mandato que
tenemos más presente no porque es muy
actual y que más ha trascendido al menos
en el extranjero Pero brevemente le pido
que repasemos las principales políticas
que ha impulsado un macron en este
primer año de su segundo mandato
Bueno sí en este primer mandato tenemos
cierto un punto de inflexión
las funciones que es seguro eso es una
una reforma que que no ha tenido
aprobación y bien antes justamente sus
reelección porque tenemos en Francia una
actualmente una una oposición y Los
vemos que se traduce tras este
impugnaturalidad Tenemos también este
una una digamos un presidente de crisis
que que también se enfrentan también a
una guerra también que le toca a Europa
y Tenemos también ecológica que es el
lema digamos de ese segundo mandato de
de manera
Sí y precisamente le pregunto macron se
presentó como de Centro en 2017 no
cuando se presentó por primera vez a la
presidencia sin embargo por ejemplo
enseguida eliminó el impuesto sobre la
fortuna también respondió con una fuerte
represión policial al movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos y ahora también hizo
lo mismo no contra las manifestaciones
en contra de la Reforma sus críticos
Además le atribuyen una posición de
desprecio hacia la clase trabajadora y
hacia los intelectuales de izquierda un
discurso además cada vez más duro contra
la inmigración le pregunto macron
siempre ha sido de derechas o se ha
derechizado
también porque lo vemos este segundo
mandato no tiene una un parlamento donde
tiene una mayoría absoluta como como el
primer mandato que que que que ha
conocido mucho son dos mandatos bien
diferentes y ahora también se rompe
también desde sus últimos meses también
un discurso también un diálogo también
con Los indicadores principales en
Francia tenemos sí Un gobierno también
que que que que que que que se enfrenta
a una oposición muy fuerte y también de
la parte de la juventud
y por parte necesita también el apoyo
también de la derecha también en Francia
para hacer pasar también sus sus
reformas
y ahora le pido que entremos más en un
análisis de lo que es el sistema
político francés en el marco de la
quinta República no y es que la semana
pasada Liberación publicó un sondeo en
que decía que la mitad de los franceses
considera que la forma de gobernar de
Manuel macron es autoritaria pero
precisamente no se enmarca en estos
poderes que otorga la Constitución
Francesa a la jefe de estado le pido que
nos explique brevemente Cuál es esta
concentración de poderes que la
izquierda a menudo Llama por ejemplo
monarquía presidencialista
de una forma una una concentración de
los poderes que que también se criticó
con bastante con el tiempo pero que
ahora
es una respuesta también de la oposición
también a sus reformas de decir que
alguna concentración del poder que no
hay diálogo
seguro Macro se enfrenta a otros
desacios muy grande en Francia es porque
es un presidente de crisis lo podemos
decir así o sea por tu segundo mandato
tiene que encontrar un nuevo camino por
el diálogo y que todavía no se ha
encontrado en Francia o sea al menos por
este segundo mandato